300 vaches laitières sont présentes sur
le salon de l'agriculture
mais comment sont-elles nourris c'est la
ferme de viltain de jouy en josas qui en
a la lourde tâche pendant les 10 jours
d'exploitation du salon elle livre à
l'aube aux portes de versailles plus de
50 tonnes de ballots de maïs ce qu'on
est tout près de paris
tous les matins il ya 5 un camion qui
vient ramassé cinq tonnes de fourrage
pour les vaches du salon donc on cultive
plus de maïs parce qu'on sait que le
salon va avoir besoin de cette
nourriture en plus la ferme profite
aussi du salon de l'agriculture pour
mettre en valeur leurs animaux ici deux
petits veaux ligny et lille a tout juste
âgé de 4 mois
on va présenter la ferme au public
francilien ça va être notre
notre clientèle beaucoup nous
connaissent déjà mais certains noms
jamais connu donc on a
mis en place des vitrines pour faire
découvrir les produits
très bien
les allées
marteau comme c'est super pour les
visiteurs du salon venir goûter ses
produits c'est aussi l'occasion
d'échanger avec les agriculteurs et pour
eux c'est un moyen simple de mettre en
valeur leur savoir faire
car ici les produits sont vendus sans
intermédiaire directement de l'éleveur
aux clients les marges meilleures prend
pour les éleveurs et la qualité en plus
traçabilité du produit donc
tout bénéfice pour tout le monde pour
l'ached à denver avec ses 350 animaux la
ferme de viltain produit plus d'un
million de litres de lait par an
faisselle fromage blanc et yaourts sont
ensuite produits et vendus sur place